herr bundespräsident das amt ist
natürlich überparteilich und doch hat
sie ihre
sagen wir mal die zeit als außenminister
aber auch als kanzleramtschef unter
merkel und dann schröder beziehungsweise
andersrum jetzt eingeholt sie haben sich
gestern bereits erklärt sie haben fehler
auch eingestanden insbesondere am
festhalten von nord stream 2 haben sie
sich als kanzleramtschef und auch als
außenminister vom russischen diktator
blenden lassen nein mit sicherheit nicht
und ich habe auch gesagt am gestrigen
tag glaube wir müssen unterscheiden
zwischen dem putin der 2001 im deutschen
bundestag geredet hat der den eindruck
erweckt hat es gebe hier die chance für
einen gemeinsamen weg zu demokratie
freiheit und zur beachtung von
menschenrechten und dem eingebürgerten
kriegstreiber putin des jahres 2022
auf der strecke in diesen 20 jahren ist
etwas passiert worüber wir länger
nachdenken müssen das wirklich traurige
ist dass wir in vielen punkten
gescheitert sind wir sind gescheitert
mit dem bemühen der errichtung eines
gemeinsamen europäischen hauses die
große vision von gorbatschow sind
gescheitert mit dem bemühen russland
einzubinden in eine europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur wir sind
gescheitert mit dem bemühen der charta
von paris
auch russland mitzunehmen auf dem weg
richtung demokratie und menschenrechten
das ist eine bittere bilanz vor der wir
stehen und zu dieser bitteren bilanz
gehört auch die fehleinschätzung dass
wir und auch ich gedacht haben
dass auch ein putin des jahres 2022 am
ende nicht den totalen
politischen wirtschaftlichen moralischen
ruinen hinnehmen würde des landes
hinnehmen würde für seine imperialen
träume oder seinen imperial war herr
bundespräsident hinterher ist man immer
schlauer aber wenn sie schon die letzten
20 jahre ansprechen da gab's
tschetschenien da gab es georgien es gab
das beseitigen so will ich es mal denn
von oppositionellen und der opposition
es gab die invasion den krieg auf die
krim wir haben giftgas in syrien und
vieles vieles mehr und sie haben gestern
selber gesagt wir haben die warnungen
von partnern ignoriert wie kann das sein
wir haben uns gerade nach 2014 noch vor
der annexion der krim auch ich
persönlich intensiv eingesetzt ich war
damals in kiel vom das morden auf den
straßen den griff zu beenden zusammen
mit dem französischen und dem und im
polnischen außenminister meine ganze
zweite amtszeit als außenminister ist
durch die ukraine und das engagement für
die ukraine geprägt aber wir haben es
auch mit
unseren unterstützungen etwa bei den
verabredungen abkommen von minsk nicht
geschafft
die entwicklung aufzuhalten die jetzt
inzwischen eingetreten ist und sich in
diesem krieg entladen hat es wird eine
lange
sie haben ja selber sagt grahmann es gab
unterschiedliche einschätzungen und die
warnungen das ist wahr von unseren
osteuropäischen partnern hätten wir
ernster nehmen müssen insbesondere was
die zeit nach 2014 anging und den ausbau
der nord stream-pipeline 2
richtig ist dass die planungen zwar alle
vor 2014 stattgefunden aber die
realisierungsphase viel in die jahre
nach 2014
und deshalb war das festhalten so habe
ich gestern gesagt sicherlich ein fehler
auch deshalb weil es am ende nicht nur
ein milliardenschweres projekt
vernichtet hat sondern weil es uns viel
kredit und glaubwürdigkeit bei unseren
osteuropäischen partnern gekostet sie
haben das europäische haus angesprochen
gerade wie sehen sie die zukunft kann es
jetzt eigentlich nur noch kann es noch
mit oder nur noch gegen putins russland
eine zukunft geben
was russland angeht muss ich ihnen sagen
weiß ich nicht ich bin sicher es wird in
dem russland unter putin keine rückkehr
zur normalität zum status quo ante geben